we're going to talk about today is
constraint satisfaction problems and
this comes from chapter 3
of both classic computer science
problems in swift and also classic
computer science problems in python
both of these books are books for people
who either are a little bit rusty on
their computer science but have been
programming for several years or maybe
people who
never had a computer science education
and
they're working as programmers or doing
programming as a hobby
and they want to get kind of a general
survey of several different computer
science topics
so one topic we cover in the book is
constraint satisfaction problems
today we'll go through some code about
them in python and then at the end i'll
do a q
a about the books or about anything
about computer science education you
want to talk about
i'll introduce myself a little bit so my
name is david kopeck
i am the author of class computer
science problems in swift and class
computer science problems in python
as well as dart for absolute beginners i
work as an assistant professor of
computer science at champlain college
i teach a wide variety of computer
science courses and i'm really excited
to be with you
and to get a chance to talk to you a
little bit about constraint satisfaction
problems in the books in general
so uh what i thought i'd do is i would
have both
a combination of the code that we'll
kind of go through
from the book and i also would actually
show you some diagrams from the book
directly that are relevant to what we'll
be talking about so i'll kind of be
switching back and forth a little bit
between some of the diagrams
and some code as well and i'll be
watching the chat in case anyone has any
questions as we go
so what is a constraint satisfaction
problem
well a constraint satisfaction problem
is what it sounds like
something where you have a problem that
has some constraints
but what is a constraint so before we
even talk about
that like title of the of the chapter
constraint satisfaction
problems let's talk about the general
idea of
variables and domains so
a variable is just like a variable in
programming
it can be something that holds multiple
different values
but at any one time might be holding
just one value
and we want to ideally set variables to
the right values
to solve some kind of problems but
what kind of values can we actually set
the variables to
well that's the purpose of domains
so domains tell us these are the
possible values
for these variables so i have an example
up here
this is a type of problem that
constraint satisfaction problems are
used a lot for solving a scheduling
problem
so we have some variables in this case
our variables are actually different
people
and maybe the people who need to make
some meeting so
mary jo and sue are our variables
and the domain might be the times that
those variables are available for the
meeting
so perhaps they're available between 2
and 4 pm
or something like that so
and then the constraints that's where
this actually becomes a constraint
satisfaction problem
those are the requirements between the
variables that need to be true
in order for the problem to be solved so
in this problem we have constraints
about who needs to be at the meeting
sue and mary need to be at the meeting
or
joe can be at the meeting so we could
have mary and
joe uh or we could have
mayor we could just have joe or we could
have
we need to have sue and mary sorry we
need to have sue and mary and we could
have joe with them or we could not have
joe but one constraint is we must have
sue and mary and the other constraint is
we may or may not have joe so if we can
find a way
to find meeting times in other words
domains for all three of these people
and we can satisfy that the right people
via those constraints can be at the
meeting then we can solve the problem
so this happens all the time i mean you
think about when you use like google
calendar
or you use apple ical and you're trying
they don't call it ical anymore right
now it's apple calendar
they and they're trying to figure out
different people's
schedules and a time that they next are
all available they're solving a
constraint satisfaction problem like
this
so this one is uh a little more involved
we're going to solve some simpler ones
over the next few minutes
but before we do that let me show you
the beginning of our python code
for going through a constraint
satisfaction problem
and then we'll go into some specific
constraint satisfaction problems
so our python code starts with defining
what a constraint is
so a cons and you'll notice i use type
hints throughout this and
i'll just say something about type ins
you know type hints
in my mind add clarity to especially
when you're reading code they make it
longer when you write code in python
but i think they had some clarity when
you're reading code but i will say it
was the most controversial
decision i made around the book was
putting type hints in
everywhere and some people love type
hints
some people really just find them a
little cluttering and they make the code
a little bit more verbose
but i use type hints throughout here if
you're not familiar with type hints
you can actually just read the code
without the type hints
and it's basically just standard python
for you without the type hints
so anytime you see a colon that's adding
in a type hint
but if you just take out the colon it's
just python without the type-ins so
you know not a lot um not a lot going
there
uh if you've never seen ins it should be
okay
and sorry my dog was barking a little
bit anyway um
so a constraint a constraint is
something between variables right
they're the
things that are constrained are the
variables so this constraint class is
really
simple all it has to do is take a list
of variables
and then make sure that all of them are
satisfied but for a generic constraint a
constraint that isn't specific to a
certain kind of problem we don't know
what it means
for that constraint to be satisfied so
if this was a scheduling problem
that satisfaction might have to do with
that all the variables
certain of the variables are available
at that time but for other kinds of
problems
there's going to be different factors
that go into whether or not
the constraint is satisfied so we're
going to end up overriding this method
satisfied in subclasses of constraint
that are implemented for our different
kinds of problems okay
so that's our constraint then we have
the general structure for holding the
entire constraint satisfaction problem
together and we call that the class csp
and csp is
a generic class again because we want to
be able to work with different types for
both the variables and the domains
so our variables might be strings
or they might be integers our domains
might be strings they might be integers
they might be something else altogether
so depending on the type of problem
we're going to have different kinds of
variables
and constraints and excuse me on domains
and
this is going to differ depending on the
specifics of the problem
and so this is where you start to see
some python type hints coming into play
here
so this is in python type in saying that
v and d could be any specific type we
don't know what type they
are at the time that we're defining the
class but in the future the user of this
class
is going to specify some types for v and
some types for d
and that type has to be the same
throughout the subclass so
variables will always be of some type
for some particular type of problem
and domains will always be of some type
for some particular type of problem
so what does a csp do though it gathers
together
variables domains and constraints it's
responsible
for associating variables with domains
and asso
and responsible for ensuring that all of
the constraints are actually satisfied
so that's what this constructor is doing
it's just assembling
variables domains and constraints as
dictionaries so that we can look them up
later on
and then when we want to add a
constraint we actually have a method
here add constraint
and what it will do just is do a sanity
check and just make sure
hey this constraint is between certain
variables do those variables actually
exist
in the problem if the variables actually
exist in the problem then we're good and
we can add this constraint in if it's
not that means there was something wrong
in the construction of the constraints
that's that's really just a sanity check
there
nothing nothing more sophisticated going
on okay
so so far we've just been doing setup
now we get into the real stuff
so consistent what's consistent
consistent looks to check if
every constraint for some particular
cons variable so remember different
constraints are going to be associated
with different variables so
constraints for some variable let's say
it was our scheduling problem let's say
all the constraints around
joe so the different constraints that
limited joe's
applicability to a meeting are all of
those satisfied
if they are then that's good and that
means that
we have a good solution so far for the
constraints for this variable
if they're not satisfied we're actually
going to have to go back
and try some different domain values for
this variable to try to solve it
and the way that we're going to do that
is through what's called a backtracking
search which is actually our next method
so i'll go into that in a minute but i
do want to mention
look how nice it is to be storing
everything in dictionaries because we
can easily just look things up by the
variable
right so we can just quickly look up
these are the constraints
associated with this variable okay
so then this is the the most
sophisticated although it's not that
sophisticated
this is the most sophisticated part of
the constraint satisfaction problem
the backtracking search this is the the
real
like meat of it this is the the part
that actually does something
so the backtracking search is
responsible for trying to find
domain values that can go in for each of
the variables
that will satisfy all of the constraints
so how does it work well every time we
do a backtracking search
we have some kind of assignment so those
are potential domain values
for the variables and
if we have the same number of
assignments as we have variables
that means we've actually assigned
everything that means that every
variable has some assignments
so we've we've found a domain value that
fits in for every variable
and that's a great thing so in that case
we're done and we actually return the
assignment because we've successfully
assigned every variable to a domain
value
however most the time until we finish
that won't be true
and so we just keep track of here which
variables don't yet have an assignment
so which variables have we not yet found
domain values for
to go into them that's what unassigned
is here and we use
a little list comprehensive
comprehension in python here to
to do that then how do we actually go
and do the search to see what domain
values
might be applicable for this variable
well this is actually if it if you've
seen depth first search before the
depth first search algorithm before this
is a form of depth first search
what we do is we first look at the first
unassigned variable
we keep track of that in a in a variable
here a python variable now not a
constraint satisfaction variable
then we go through all the potential
domains for that variable so we're just
going to go through them one by one
in the original order that they were put
into the domains
and for each of them we create a new
potential assignment
taking the old assignment because the
old assignment will have the domains for
all the previous variables
and we add in this one just one new
variables
assignment and we add that to this new
what we call local assignment
and if it turns out that remember that
method we did consistent which checks
all the constraints
if it turns out that this new assignment
combined with all of the old ones
together
is consistent so that means all the
constraints are satisfied
then we're good and that means this was
a good assignment
and in that case we do we call
backtracking search recursively
and what will happen is then let's go
back to the top here
the assignment will now become what was
the local assignment
now with one more variable successfully
filled in
with a domain value for it and that
means that now we can move on to yet one
more
unassigned variable or if we're totally
done we'll just return the assignment
so it's actually a pretty simple
recursive
depth first search going on here if
you're not familiar with depth first
search i could understand that this
would look pretty intimidating
but great news is a depth research is
actually covered in chapter 2 of the
book
so we cover depth first search in
chapter 2 of the book and then in
chapter three
in constraint satisfaction problems we
kind of assume that you have that
knowledge about depth first search
but basically depth first search uh let
me give you
an idea about it as an analogy in the
real world so
if you had an onion and there was
something like
inside of your onion somewhere maybe
there was some insect crawling around
inside of it it's kind of a
nasty example but i'll do it anyway
there's some insect crawling inside of
your onion and you want to find it right
there's two main strategies you might
use there's breath first search where
you might kind of peel the onion back
one layer at a time looking for that
insect
and then there's depth first search
where you might just kind of stick a
knife into the onion and you hope you
found it
you just went really deep really fast
and you weren't doing it super
methodically
you went and you tried a bunch of values
tried a bunch of places to search for it
and you didn't quite find it so then you
backtracked to the last place you were
and you
stick it the knife in a little bit
differently and hope you found the um
the insect that way it's not always the
most efficient way to do things
and this is not the most efficient way
to necessarily to solve a constraint
satisfaction problem
but it is a um it certainly works
and it's one that's very simple to
illustrate which is why we use this
this method in the in the book in
chapter three okay
so now let's use this framework to try
to solve some specific
actual problems so this was all just
build up to be able to try to solve a
problem but let's try some actual
variables
some actual domains and some actual
constraints
so i'm going to open back up the
the preview here of some of the problems
from the book
and let's look at the australian map
coloring problem
so here's the problem we have the nation
of australia
and australia has multiple different
regions i think
some of them are territories and some of
them are provinces
but i'll just call all of them regions
and
what we want to do is we want to color
each of the different
parts of australia with a different
color
and we're going to have three different
colors that we can use we can use maybe
blue green and red
so the question is can we make the
computer automatically color them for us
so us as human beings don't need to do
it not that
this is like a very hard problem to do
as a human being in fact if you try
doing it yourself with a blank map of
australia
you can probably do it in just a few
minutes but it's often used as a first
problem in constraint satisfaction
problem solving
education i guess or teaching because
it's so easy to think about and reason
about
so if we think about this what are our
variables and what are our domains here
so the variables would be each of the
different regions
and we could think about them as just
strings in our program so
they could be strings like western
australia the string western australia
could be one of them that's that's a
variable
northern territory could be a string
what are the domains the domains are
what colors
we could fill in for those variables so
we have three different colors here
we have red green and blue so the domain
is actually going to be the same for
every variable because western australia
could be red green or blue depending on
how we solve the problem
south australia could be red green or
blue
depending on how we solve the problem
now what's the constraint well that's
where the problem actually gets
interesting the point of this is that we
don't want to have and i should have
maybe said it at the beginning
we don't want to have any of the two
regions next to each other
having the same color so we want to make
sure that every two regions next to each
other have a different color
so we want western australia to have a
different color from northern territory
but we also want western australia to
have a different color from south
australia
so we want to make sure there's always
no two regions that
border each other are adjacent to each
other that have the same color
so that's going to be our constraint so
now that we have a constraint
satisfaction problem solving framework
how can we actually now codify the
problem and the constraints
so actually i think before we even look
at the constraint
let's look at how we codified the
variables so my variables here
are just a list of strings each string
representing
one region of australia the domains
are just going to be strings that
represent the different colors so the
domains can be
red green blue and they can be red green
or blue for
any of the regions and so we're just
going to go through all the variables
and assign the domains red green and
blue to all of them
it was that easy now that we have this
framework in place it was that simple to
define variables and constraints and
we've actually just defined almost the
whole problem
the last part is the constraints so the
constraints are
that we don't want to have two regions
next to each other that have the same
color right so before i go and we look
at all this code for adding all the
constraints let's look at how
a constraint is actually defined so
a map coloring constraint is a subclass
of the constraint class that we looked
at earlier and remember that constraint
we said before
was generic in that the variables and
the domains could be any type
but now in this problem we have specific
types we know that all the variables are
going to be python strings
they're going to be things like western
australia
northern territory and we know that the
domains are also going to be strings
they're going to be things like red
green or blue and so
when we end up subclassing constraint
here we can actually now fill in the
types
and string is going to fill in for the
variable type and string is also going
to fill in for the domain type
so therefore a map color and constraint
is going to be a constraint between
variables that are strings that have
domains that are strings and other
variables that are strings that have
domains that are strings so when we
initialize a new map coloring constraint
what we want to provide it are the two
places so
remember it's always going to be between
two adjacent regions of australia
so that's going to be places like um
northern australia and western australia
that's gonna be places like or sorry
northern territory sorry if there's any
australians listening
things like northern territory in south
australia it's always two of them that
we're constraining so that's what place
one and place two are
and then how are they satisfied well we
wanna make sure that they don't have the
same
domain so they don't have the same color
how do we check that they don't have the
same color
well it's this really simple line here
not equal to
how simple is that right we want to make
sure that red is not equal to green
right we want to make sure red is not
equal to blue blue is not equal to green
we want to just make sure that they're
not the same the same string
you might wonder why is this first line
in here
well we can't even do a check if we
haven't yet assigned
both of them so for example if i've
assigned a color for western australia
but i haven't yet assigned a color for
northern territory
then there's really no way for me to
actually check between the two of them
whether this the constraint is satisfied
so
in that case i i just returned true
because i want to keep going
until i actually have some kind of
assignment for both of them but once i
have an assignment for both them it's as
simple as just checking that it's not
the same assignment so it's really
straightforward
then here's the code for actually adding
in all the constraints now this part
was done manually right so there was no
way to automatically know
it would have been cool maybe if i'd
used some machine learning and read in
the map file and it automatically
figured out that this region is has this
name
and it's next to this region that is
this name but here we just manually
this is basically our map this is us
manually adding constraints in
for each of the adjacent regions so
we're adding in western australia to
northern territory
et cetera et cetera right victoria to
new south wales
because they're next to each other
victoria to tasmania so any two that are
adjacent we need to have a constraint
between them
so we just added in all these
constraints here then we're just calling
methods on what we defined earlier
remember earlier on we defined the
constraint satisfaction
class to have the backtracking search
method we're just searching through
and if we found a solution we print out
the solution
and if we didn't find a solution we
print out no solution found
so let me try running it let's see what
the results look like
so it colored them successfully so first
of all we know that because it didn't
just print out no solution found
and the solution is that western
australia should be red
northern territory should be green south
australia should be
blue et cetera et cetera et cetera and
that is if you look here that's actually
what we illustrated here
in the um in the diagram in the book was
the solution obviously
so okay you might be saying that seemed
like a lot of work
to solve that problem that seemed like
you did
a lot of setup there a lot of
preparation
to solve what looks like not that hard a
problem
well what i think is more interesting
here
is how we can reuse that same framework
now to solve different kinds of problems
so let's solve two or three other
problems that look quite
different from the map coloring problem
using the same exact framework
and what i'll do for that is i will go
over to the next diagram so we can
illustrate the next problem
so this is called the eight queens
problem
here's the challenge you have a
chessboard and
what you want to do is you want to
actually
place eight queens on the chessboard so
that none of them are threatening each
other or
attacking each other depending on what
your parlance is so this is an actual
potential solution here
now for those who don't play chess the
way that queens work
is they can actually move both
diagonally and they can also move
vertically and horizontally across
columns and rows
so they're the most powerful piece in
the game and they can
they can just glide across the board to
any square that's within
a diagonal that's not blocked by
something within a a row or column
so in this case if you follow the
diagonals let's say we follow the queen
on c7
if you follow the diagonals or you
follow the
the row here or the column you'll see
there's no other queen
within any of those places so
therefore this is a queen that
that is a good part of a solution to the
a queen's problem because it's not
threatening or attacking any other
queens
so the question is can we place all
eight of them on the board
without any of them threatening or
attacking
any other queens and there's actually
more than one solution to this problem
so there's there's actually many
different boards
that have the queens in different places
that successfully solves a problem
but we just want to try to find one
solution can we just find one solution
to this
to this problem so we won't go back to
csp because we already solved that
that's the great thing right we already
know what a constraint satisfaction
problem looks like what we can do is we
can now just define
different kinds of constraints and then
we can solve totally different kinds of
problems
so using the same framework so here we
have a queen's constraint
and a queen's constraint is going to
between be between variables that are
integers
and the domains that are integers why is
that
well we can actually think about the
variables in this case being the
different potential
columns of the of that the queen could
be on so
that can be like columns a through h on
this board
or we just use integers so and you know
in computing we usually start counting
at zero right
so we could also think about it as
columns zero through seven
and the same thing for the rows right we
can think about these as being rows zero
through seven
or i might have actually done one
through eight in the code i need to
remind myself i did one through eight
so one through eight can be the columns
and one through eight can be the rows
so the csp then is going to then
end up associating each of the queens on
different
columns and by the way we know all the
queens have to be on different columns
right
because if any of the queens were on the
same columns they would be attacking
each other
so we know right off the bat it's like a
little trick that we have to put every
queen on a separate column right
but then what we don't know is which row
to put them all in once we've already
put all of them into separate columns
hey teal hi from usa nice to see you
from spain
um so knowing that all these different
queens
are on different columns how do we
figure out the right row
well again we can just have our csp do a
backtracking search to solve that
so we've set up all the columns as our
variables we've set up the different
possible rows
as our domains and then we just
implement a csp that has our
constraint satisfaction problem that has
columns for the variables
rows for the domains really
straightforward
but then we have to add in the
constraint and this time you'll notice
it's a different kind of constraint
so in the map coloring problem that we
looked at before
the constraint was always between two
different
locations on the map two different
regions of australia
now this problem the constraint is
actually between
all of the different variables at once
right the constraint is actually that
we have to look at every queen at the
same time because we're not just looking
at two at a time it's it's
good if two of them are not attacking
each other but we want each of them to
not be attacking
all the other queens so it's a different
kind of constraint here
it's a constraint where we're looking at
actually a list
perhaps of all the different potential
queens
so how do we satisfy that constraint how
do we satisfy a constraint between
all of the possible different queens i
don't think
there's some other problems i want to
cover so i don't think we have to go
through this in a huge amount of detail
but i'll go through it in
a little bit we look at the the column
and the row
of each queen and so you could think
about this as the first queen
so this is like queen one column queen
one row is what i meant by
the q1c the q1r here then we look at
each of the other queens and so i call
the other queens like q2c
is queen two column and queen two row
so we're going to end up looking at q1c
and q1r
for one queen and then q2c and q2r is
gonna be
each of the other queens so we have a
total of eight queens right
so uh the first queen is going to be
always q1c and q1r and then the other
seven queens
are gonna one at a time be q2c and q2r
hey max good to see you so
having q1c and q1r together with q2c and
q2r we can then just compare them again
this is like in the
australian map coloring problem it's a
simple check we just need to check
they're not
the same right if they are the same
that's not good
that means we have not solved the
problem if we have two queens on the
same row
obviously we haven't solved the problem
the other check here is for diagonals
and using absolute values here is just a
quick way
of checking if the two are on the same
diagonal so in other words here we're
checking
are these two queens on the same row if
they're on the same row that's not good
we didn't solve the problem
and then in the second one we're just
checking are these two queens on the
same diagonal
if they're on the same diagonal we also
did not solve the problem
however if they're not on the same row
and they're not on the same diagonal
and then we've gotten through comparing
this queen to all the other queens
then we've successfully solved the
problem and that means that we return
true
so again it's a simple comparison and
the machinery for doing all the
searching was already implemented by
backtracking search back in
the constraint satisfaction problem so
here we can
do a totally different kind of problem
and solve it using the same framework so
let me try running this
and we will see what we get now this
might look a little cryptic but what
this is here
is this is each queen at some potential
column with the row that it should be on
to solve the problem so we solved here
that queen
the queen on column one should be on row
one the queen on column two should be on
row five
the queen on column three should be on
row eight and if we followed all these
and put them on the chessboard
they would not be attacking one another
and we would get a position
that looks like our final diagram here
which is
having all the queens on places where
they're not attacking any other queens
so i hope you see that at least in my
mind this is quite a different kind of
problem than the
australian map coloring problem but
because we're able to break it down
into variables domains and constraints
we can solve it using the same generic
framework
okay let's try another problem so we've
done the australian map coloring problem
we've done
um we've done the eight queens problem
which are both pretty classic problems
here's a problem that everyone i'm sure
is familiar with this is a word search
so in this problem we have different
words that we want to put in a grid of
letters
and we want to make it so that the words
are legally within the grid of letters
without necessarily
overriding one another for lack of a
better word right
so they need to safely all be able to
fit in there
successfully so how can we fit different
size words
all into this grid is basically the the
challenge of
the word search problem now this one's a
little bit more involved and so i think
i'm going to go through
the general outline of it and how it
uses the constraint satisfaction problem
framework
but um i won't go through maybe the
details of how we constructed
all of every part of it so
let me open that up sorry going to the
wrong chapter there word search
is this similar to linear programming
yes linear programming can be thought of
as
a more advanced technique than this
generalized backtracking search
to solve constraint satisfaction
problems but yeah in linear programming
you also have constraints
between variables usually they're logic
constraints between variables
and so there's a there's a very
significant overlap between constraint
satisfaction problems and linear
programming it's a great
great question so
to figure out a word search in this case
we have
a few different helper classes we have a
grid location that's like a location
on the on the word search grid somewhere
a row and a column
we also have a grid and a grid is just
going to be
a two dimension what in other
programming languages we call a
two-dimensional
uh array but in python we call it a list
of lists
so a list of lists of strings where each
string is really just going to be a
letter
so i could maybe use a character or
something like that but it's
really just a single letter somewhere on
the grid
so having a grid of letters having
locations on the grid
then we start to have these methods for
constructing a grid and again i won't go
into all of these in a huge amount of
detail but
what this is basically doing is
generating a random grid
by using the some built-in nice stuff
from the python standard library
and this is just displaying a grid it's
just printing it all out
then we get to the parts that are
actually related to a constraint
satisfaction problem
so generate domain generate domain is
going to go and figure out
for one potential variable and i should
have said what is a variable in this
well let me
have you think about that for a second
as i go back to the problem here
what is actually one of our variables
what do you think
a variable would be one of the words
that we want to put on the grid
so in this case we're putting names on
so like sarah would be a variable
matthew would be a variable the domains
are all of the potential places that we
could
put that variable on the grid so for
example
it depends if we start counting from the
bottom or from the top here but let's
say we started counting
from the top going down and from the top
going to from the left going to the
right
so we can say that matthew was actually
placed at location
like 1 1 if we start counting at zero
right and then each of his individual
letters
was placed in some additional locations
as well that's really the domain is like
where are the potential places
that we could put a word in the grid so
again this is like a different kind of
problem right than the eight queens
problem or the australian map coloring
problem
but you'll see we're able to solve it
using the same framework
okay so i won't again i won't go into
all the details here because i do want
to get to one more problem after this
but generate domain
looks through the entire grid and tries
to find locations that it could
potentially put one of those words
and it gathers together all those
different locations that words can go
and those cumulative locations are
the potential domains for each of the
variables so those are the places
that we could put those those words
those are the places we could put the
words that's the domain
and then what is a constraint in this
case
a constraint is going to be a check to
make sure
that we're not putting words on top of
each other right
i don't want to put up the word for the
first letter for matthew is an
m right and the first letter for sarah
is an s
right if i overwrite the m with an
s then i actually
do not successfully construct a word
search problem right
so i need to make sure that i'm not
overwriting one letter with another
letter from a different word
and so actually that's pretty simple
here all i'm doing here
is again just checking that we don't
have any of them on the same location
and how do i do that well this is a
convenient trick that you use in
programming a lot
is if you want to eliminate duplicates
you can just change over from
a um a list to a set or if i was in
another programming language i'd be
saying i'm going from an array to a set
anytime you go from a list to a set
or in another programming language an
array to a set you're going to eliminate
duplicates because by definition
sets are not allowed to have duplicates
of the same value
so what we end up with in the end
is we end up with just the the
non-duplicated locations
for some assignments and we check
is that the same number of locations as
we originally had in the assignments
if that's true that after eliminating
duplicates
we still had the same number that would
mean
that we didn't actually have any
overlaps so
i hope you see here how the converting
things to a set is really helping us
check for duplicates
and then by checking for duplicates
we're actually checking that nothing is
overlapping or overwriting one another
so i hope that you can kind of see how
that fits together but look how compact
that is right
just two lines of code and we've checked
that we don't have any overlapping
locations
look how simple word circuit constraint
is right this is where we're overriding
again
something from the original csp
problem that we looked at at the
beginning of the stream right and the
types again it's a generic type
and i i know not everyone loves the type
hints but let me just mention how the
type hints fit in here
we're saying that the variables in this
problem are strings
and remember those are again the words
so in our example i'll open up the
example again
that's like matthew or mary or sarah
those are all strings right
and then the places that matthew can go
or the places that mary or sarah can go
those are grid locations and we looked
at the grid location class earlier
and so the cumulative places that they
can go is a list of grid locations
and so a list of grid locations is what
makes up the um
the domain for each of those variables
okay
so we defined our word search
constraints we defined what
what the actual variables are and in
this case i just use those those
variables matthew joe mary sarah sally
they're just strings
we define what the domains are we use
that method generate domain
to figure out all the potential
different places
that the um that the each of the words
can go
and then we generated a csp just as we
did before and again the csp
class doesn't change it's the same exact
class for solving all these different
kinds of problems
and we added in a word search
constraints to make sure that
none of the individual words ends up
overlapping or overwriting one another
and then we just run a backtracking
search and it's that simple if we were
successful
then we're good and we can go printing
out the uh the final grid
if we were not successful uh then we it
turns out that probably we had too many
words
or we had some words that were so long
that they couldn't fit within the grid
with other words and so they ended up
having to overwrite each other and so we
couldn't find a way to put them all in
but let's try running it here
and of course i chose an example where i
knew we could solve it but but here you
see a solution
at the bottom here where we've managed
to fit all the different words that we
wanted to fit
um in here somehow i see matthews up
here here's sarah
i think joe is upside down here um and
there's probably some more in the other
well they must be the other ones must be
in there as well
anyway okay so that's another totally
different kind of problem but because we
could still define it using variables
domains and constraints we could still
solve it the same way using a
backtracking search
and a constraint satisfaction problem
framework let's do one more and this
will be our last one okay and then i'll
take some of your questions about the
books or
about computer science education or
anything else you'd like to talk about
but our last kind of problem is another
classic problem it's called
send plus more equals money and maybe
you tried to do this some point
in a math class when you were growing up
maybe in elementary school or middle
school probably middle school
you tried to solve this problem at some
point it's a crypt arithmetic problem
and what that means is we have
characters that are supposed to
represent digits
and so let me make this even bigger
because i it's probably a little small
for you on the screen
so we have send plus more
and each of these letters is supposed to
represent a different digit zero through
nine
so for example maybe d is supposed to be
four hypothetically
or maybe e is supposed to be seven then
any time that we
see that same letter we expect the same
digit to be able to fill
in to make the problem and its solution
true
so anytime we see an e we expect there
to be a seven
so if there was going to be a seven here
we expect there to also be a seven here
and also a seven here if we can find
digits that can fit in for each of the
letters
then we can successfully solve the
problem so before i should go and show
you the code
i want you to be thinking about this
right now what
is the variables here what is the
domains
and what are the potential constraints
or the constraints
between all of these there might just
i'll give you a hint there might just be
one constraint in this case although you
could
i could think of a way you could
formulate it with multiple constraints
but there's one really obvious
constraint here
but what do you think the variables are
what do you think the domains are
and what do you think the constraint is
and let me go
because we're not going to run out of
time i am going to open it up
we're already at 7 42 and i did want to
leave some time to take questions about
the books
so let's go right into it so
i'll take away the the suspense the
variables could potentially be
all the different letters okay so each
of the individual letters could be our
variables
the domains would be the digits that can
try to fit in for each of those letters
so each of the letters could potentially
be the letters 0 through 9
we don't know what the right answer is
yet but that's what they potentially
could be
to solve the problem so notice the
constraints by the way we don't
excuse me in the variables we don't
duplicate our letters right
because even though the e ends up being
in the problem three times right
there's only one letter e that we're
trying to solve for even though we see
the letter e
three times there's only one value that
we're trying to find for letter e
because it's going to be the same value
in every location
right okay so uh
let me just go back now to to the code
so we have our domain we have our
variables
last part as you've seen the pattern now
right
is we always have to have a constraint
so
the constraint in this case the send
more money constraint
is really really straightforward in fact
it might be our most straightforward
constraint other than the australian map
coloring problem that we did earlier
it's really straightforward because the
problem spells out the constraint for
you
the constraint is that whatever values
we assigned for the letters
this equation has to be true send plus
more
has to equal money right that is the
constraint
so what do we do let's just do a little
bit of arithmetic
for whatever letters we've assigned what
excuse me whatever digits we've assigned
to the letters
let's just do the arithmetic and see if
they solve the problem and that would
that would be a solution or constraint
so let's see here looking at satisfied
the first thing we'll check is have we
actually tried
assigning some value to every letter so
until we've actually tried giving every
letter a value
there's no point in actually doing the
arithmetic right because if i don't have
a value i can't there's nothing for me
to add up
so i need to actually have values but
once i have
all the different potential values let's
see what i can do well i can actually
construct the equation here
how can i construct the equation well
look at where each of these lo
these items is right if this was a um
if this was just a number here right
this would be the the d
would be in the ones place the n would
be in the tens place
the e would be in the hundreds place and
the s would be in the thousands place
right and so what i can do is i can just
multiply
each of the potential digits by its
placement numerically and i will end up
getting the
the number that that together they
represent
so i end up calculating what send
represents i end up calculating what
more represents and i end up calculating
what money represents
using the domain values that have filled
in for the variables
that are represented by the letters then
i just check
is send plus more equal equal to money
if they are this means
that we actually have solved the seven
plus more equals money problem
how easy was that right it was so
similar to some of these other
constraint satisfaction problems that
we've done
and yet it's so different it's so
different in that
when you look at this problem right when
i look at this problem
i don't see a map i don't see the
australian map coloring problem
so you have to realize what are
variables what are domains and how can
they be constrained between each other
but there's a huge wide variety of
problems that can actually be solved
this way
anyway let's try running this and try
seeing if we have a solution of course i
know we do and if it doesn't run right
now and doesn't give us a solution
that's really bad because it's in the
book right
so anyway so here's a potential solution
so if you go and fill this in you'll see
that this actually ends up being send
plus more equals money and i'll show you
that i think i have
of course i would have put this in the
book um it's uh
after the end here the solution here i
know what i should have done
this is a good thing for the second
edition of the book i should have lined
up the numbers again here
right i should have lined up each of the
numbers again and spelled out to prove
to you that they actually
solve for one another but anyway if you
line up the digits and you put them in
the right places now you'll see it does
add up send plus more does equal money
um anyway so we made it through
four different constraint satisfaction
problems and the key thing i wanted to
take away is that we were able to use
the same backtracking search
and the same very simple framework for
setting up a constraint satisfaction
problem to solve all of them
i imagine in your software development
tasks whether you're a professional
software developer or hobbyist software
developer
you come across problems that could be
solved using this framework
i'm not saying that the version that we
implemented here is the most efficient
way to solve these problems
it's not necessarily and there's other
extensions to constraint satisfaction
problems that we could talk about but
probably beyond the scope of today
things like rearranging the order
that we look at the constraints in to go
through them as efficiently as possible
or going through the variables that have
the most constraints put on them first
or the least constraints put on them
first that kind of ordering can actually
make us go through the potential
solutions more quickly and then there's
also a whole different way not using a
backtracking search but using a totally
different method that's way beyond our
scope today called forward checking
that can sometimes be more efficient in
trying to solve one of these problems
if you want now my book is a book that
gives you a
really broad overview of different kinds
of problems
it's not a deep book in the sense that
i'm not going to explain to you
every every single different way to
solve a constraint satisfaction problem
or every way to make it more efficient
i'm going to just introduce you to the
idea of a constraint satisfaction
problem
show you a real way of solving them as
we did here
and then if you want to go further of
course there's whole books on the
subject
one i would recommend is artificial
intelligence a modern approach
covers constraint satisfaction problems
in chapter 6 of that book
so if you want to go in a lot of depth
into this chapter 6 of that book is
great
but if you just want to get the first
introduction chapter 3 of my book is a
great first introduction
and you can also manning is offering
that for free right now
through live books on the website and we
also have an article
that is linked to from the constraint
satisfaction excuse me from the class
computer science problems and python
page
that goes through this as well and kind
of walks you through the code and all
the code i went on here today is on my
github repository for the book
so if my github username is davecom i
should have put a link in somewhere
i can do that in the chat later but um
you can go on my repository davecom
d-a-v-e-c-o-m
find class computer science problems in
python repository and you'll find all
this code on there as well
okay now that we made it through this uh
i'd like to take
questions about the books about computer
science education
about anything else you want to talk
about so i'll look at the chat
and see if anyone's asking any questions
and if we don't i have some
some pre-made questions that i'll answer
if nobody has any questions
oh and thank you so i just saw in the
chat that there's a link to my repo that
manning's already put up so
you can go check that out and there you
can get all the code from today's
presentation as well
okay since i'm not seeing any questions
i'll go through a pre-made
question okay so let's say the question
was
who are these books suitable for and
that's one of the most common questions
that i get
is who are these books suitable for so
the class computer science problem
series is not for beginner
programmers so it's not really for
people as their first book in
programming
it's for people who already have an
intermediate or advanced knowledge of
the language in question
so class computer science problems in
swift i wouldn't give to somebody
who's just um going into swift for the
first time
uh i would give it to somebody who's
already been probably doing swift for
like
maybe you know six months to a year then
pick up class computer science problems
in swift
because it's it's really more about
using the language as a vehicle
to learn the computer science topics and
the problem solving techniques
more than it is about learning the
language so of course there's tons of
great books about
learning swift there's several good
books from manning there's
also apple's free book which is an all
right book as well
but once you've picked up those first
books then go on to class computer
science problems in swift when you want
to learn
more uh about computer science but using
swift as a vehicle
same thing for the python book it's you
don't have to have a computer science
education though
so you don't have to be uh somebody who
had a four-year degree in computer
science to read these books in fact
a large part of the number of people
that read the books
are people who didn't go to school for
computer science and they want to know
what these topics are about
they want to know how to solve different
kinds of problems appropriately
they want to know when their colleagues
or friends talk about different
programming problem-solving techniques
what they really mean
so actually self-taught programmers is
one of the biggest audiences
of the books but with that in mind you
do need to already be a programmer you
can't come into the books
never having programmed before um okay
so
i see a couple questions here from the
chat let me answer a couple of them the
first one
with the depth first search what's the
size of the problem that start causing
some performance problems
and what would be the best way to solve
it well that's a great question uh let
me give this to you let me
give this to you in a real world example
that'll help you see why depth first
search can sometimes
not make that much sense let's say i was
trying to find
the least number of train stops
between boston and seattle in the united
states
for those of you that aren't from the
united states boston is on the far
eastern seaboard of the united states
and seattle is on the far
western side of the united states
now new york is also on the eastern
seaboard and it's pretty close
to uh to boston okay
and actually let's make let's change the
problem a little bit let's say i'm
trying to find a train that goes from
boston to new york that's much closer
together okay
depth first search we don't specify that
we're first going to check
the closest locations to boston we're
just going to go deep right away
so maybe we first go from boston to
montreal and canada
and then we go to toronto and canada and
then we end up at seattle
and then we go from seattle all the way
back to new york
on the east coast using depth for search
that could potentially be a solution
that we find
which would not be great that would not
be the best way to get from boston to
new york by train
using breadth first search we would
first look
one station away from boston in every
direction so we'd first maybe go from
boston to bangor maine and we first go
from boston to
uh you know concord new hampshire
montpelier
vermont or something and then we'd go
from boston to new haven connecticut we
look at these places just one stop
away from boston then we look at places
two stops away from boston
maybe when we got to two or three stops
away from boston we get to new york
with depth first search we might have
dug really far in the wrong direction
before we got to the place we were
looking to go with breath for search
we would have carefully and methodically
gone one space out at a time
until we got to the location that we
really wanted to get to
and so that's just one example of a
situation where breadth first
where depth first search excuse me might
not be the most efficient way to solve a
problem
but for problems where you don't have
that many variables and that many
constraints
it's fine uh for simple the problems
that we've dealt with today as you saw
in when i ran them even on my laptop
here they
they were answered instantaneously right
so if you have a problem with
only a few variables only a few domains
only a few constraints up to let's say
even you know
a dozen or more um there's this even
though this technique is not one that i
would use in production on some big data
set
if you have a simple problem like the
ones we went through today it's
perfectly legitimate
to use uh a simple uh depth first search
as we did with the backtracking search
okay let me go to the next question here
and there's all kinds i actually i want
to say also there's a really good
explanation of depth first search versus
breadth first search
versus the a star algorithm which is a
much more advanced algorithm
in chapter two of the book actually i
think it's one of you know it's my book
so of course i'm going to say it's good
right but i think it's one of the best
parts of the book is chapter two of the
book
goes through depth first search breadth
first search and a star search
and uh i think it's a pretty strong part
of the book okay next question here
is there any reason you pick swift as a
programming language for the book
okay um so
when i originally did the first book i
was working on it in the 2016-2017 time
frame
i finished at the end of 2017 and it
came out at the beginning of 2018.
um and at that time i was thinking about
this series
as bringing computer science education
to emerging languages so languages that
might
not yet have good computer science books
in them now that was true at that time
in swift and so i thought okay i'm going
to be a niche i'm going to be the first
like computer science book
for swift and you know that book did
okay
and it's been it's a i think it's a
great book uh but
it turns out that there was actually a
much bigger demand
for this type of book than i thought
somebody people were looking for
something that was somewhere between
an uh you know a tutorial and a textbook
they wanted something that was more
approachable
that was broad that that dipped into a
lot of different computer science topics
correctly
importantly of course verified by
technical reviewers and a real public
great real publisher like manning
but they didn't want something that's as
boring and and you know uh
hard to get through as a textbook and so
the publisher said to me after we did
the swift book which was you know the
swift book was pretty successful they
said
we got to bring this to a much bigger
audience and so
then we did the the python book and the
python book has just been really
successful
it's been a bestseller for manning it's
been translated now into seven different
human languages that came out at the
beginning of 2019
and so we see that there's really a
demand in um the large languages
like the popular the really popular
languages uh to have a book like this
and so we're actually porting the book
next to java i'm working on that right
now
because we're doing just the next like
really big language right and we did a
poll of our readers we said
do you want the book in um we've done
the book in swift
we're doing it in python this was back
in the beginning of 2019
do you want the book next in java c
sharp javascript
uh rust um there were people who wanted
it in haskell like all over the place
and i actually thought maybe we'll do it
in go and a lot of people wanted and go
but we realized based on the poll and
also based on market research that the
best next language to bring it to was
java in terms of the number of people
that were looking for something like
this probably
so we're doing class computer science
problems in java and that's going to
come out
at the end of this year okay next
question here
what would you recommend is further
learning research areas after getting
through one of your class computer
science problems books well thanks for
that question that's a really good
question
i would say the next thing you would
want to go to after that
would be a deep book on data structures
and algorithms if you haven't already
done that
so i'm going to recommend a few
different books if you want a more
informal style kind of like my book
then i'm going to recommend groking
algorithms which is a manning title
and grocking algorithms is a really good
book i've read it myself i think it's
excellent
and i've actually um i actually use
groking algorithms when i teach data
structures and algorithms at the college
level
i don't use it completely it's not a
deep enough book to cover every subject
in it
but i use it for part of the course and
i think rocking algorithms
is an excellent manning title and um
really props to the author i think it's
adida i
forgot the name off the top my head but
but he did a really fantastic job so
grocking algorithms is probably the next
book i would go to after mine and it's
also in python so if you're doing the
python book
it's really great but if you're not
doing the python book it's also easy
enough to read python code
that you could totally uh understand it
even if you're not a pythonista
if you want to go deeper than that then
there are of course the classic data
structures and algorithms and artificial
intelligence textbooks and
the class computer science problems
books they touch on both data structures
and algorithms
and they also touch on artificial
intelligence we get into topics like
neural networks in them
and clustering and things like that but
so if you want to go even deeper into
those i do think the classic textbooks
in those areas are pretty good
so the most classic textbook is probably
introduction to algorithms by
clrs shout out to tom corman if he's
reading
are watching he's he was my professor
back in college and he wrote one of
those textbooks
uh or most of one of the or a
significant portion of one of those
textbooks
and uh it's a great reference
introduction to algorithms
if you like math it's really pretty deep
on the math
but it does everything in pseudo code if
you're looking for something that's a
little more
a little less mathy and a little bit
more easy to read and in real code
i recommend algorithms by sedgwick which
is actually in java and is also used a
lot in college classrooms just like
introduction algorithms is
it's just a little bit more readable for
some people but it depends what your
disposition is more
would you rather see the code in a real
programming language or would you rather
see the code as pseudocode with math
those two textbooks are the two
standards really introduction algorithms
by corman and i don't know what the lrs
stands for i forgot off the top of my
head
and algorithms by sedgwick and wayne
those are really the two best probably
algorithms textbooks
but i think rocky algorithms is a good
place to start if you want artificial
intelligence
i recommend the classic book artificial
intelligence a modern approach
which is the standard artificial in
textbook if you want a more approachable
textbook my dad who's actually deceased
unfortunately but he wrote an artificial
intelligence textbook a few years ago
that's called artificial intelligence in
the 21st century
and that's also a a pretty good
artificial intelligence textbook
which is more approachable than the
classic text artificial intelligence a
modern approach so but all those
textbooks are good sorry i want to use
tangent about textbooks let me go the
next question
next question
when i was going through the book i was
learning a lot of new syntax
that wasn't the normal guides how do i
learn more in depth parts of a language
for example
the underscore being in front of the
functions to make them hidden
okay all right great great great
question
um so i there's a book i'm gonna i'm
recommending a lot of books today
but uh the book that i'm gonna recommend
for getting deeper into python c
syntax is fluent python
fluent python now maybe manning doesn't
like this but it's actually an o'reilly
book unfortunately but
grocking algorithms really great manning
book fluent python is an o'reilly book
that i do recommend
and it's really excellent and it goes
deep into every little facet of python
syntax i don't think it's a type of book
you have to read the whole thing from
cover to cover
i didn't do that you can just go into
the chapters that interest you or that
are important to the type of syntax that
you're interested in
but fluent python will really teach you
to write in a
pythonic way uh
okay let's see are you expanding into
other languages i already answered that
we're expanding into java
next that's going to be our next
language and i know there's people that
want other languages so we'll see how
the java book
goes and we might continue to go from
there
what do i think of algorithm design by
kleinberg and tardos
i haven't read that one i've heard i
hear a lot about that one but
i've read a lot of other algorithm books
or at least
skimmed a lot of other algorithm books
i've read cover to cover
um a few of them but um i haven't read
that one so i can't comment on it i've
heard good things from other people
though
uh okay what language would you say
are better to to begin to experiment
writing a domain-specific language with
oh that's an interesting question
i wouldn't say that that's really my
area of expertise so i don't want to
guide you
wrongly i've seen people build
domain-specific languages in a variety
of languages
i know that some people love to build
them in functional languages like
haskell
i personally that's not my cup of tea
really but
you know there are some really good
libraries in haskell for doing that
but um i think honestly i think it's the
language that
you're most comfortable in when you're
first starting out in any topic
that's what i find now i have written
programming books now in
three different languages and working on
the fourth my first book was in dart and
i did swift and i did python
my professional career was largely in
ios development so doing a lot of
objective c
and then swift and then doing python a
lot for web projects
but i think anytime i start a new topic
so it's good to start in a language that
i'm really comfortable in
uh and so sometimes being more
comfortable in a language i think
outweighs
um outweighs having a really good
library sometimes like having an okay
library
in a language that you're an expert in
sometimes is nicer than having a great
library
in a language that you're really gonna
struggle with just to tell a little war
story
um i did a startup when i was
uh just out of graduate school so this
was like eight years ago
and i went and the project was being
built in ruby on rails
and i came and joined and i had to take
over the project
and i was not an expert in ruby and i
was not an expert in ruby on rails and i
had to learn it on the job as i was
going
and ruby on rails is a great framework
uh but
i probably would have done having a lot
of python experience already at that
point
i probably would have done a lot better
in
a lesser framework in python than
working in ruby on rails because i was
just
i was a newbie to both rails and to ruby
so i would just say in general my
general advice to students usually
is when you're starting a new topic
better to pick a language that you're an
expert in at first um than to
pick a language just for its library
unless the library is so good you know
you have to wait of course there's pros
and cons but maybe i went on
too much of a tangent there too um
okay i think that's all the questions we
have and we've gone just over
our hour uh so i'll just give a final
couple of plugs
um so i'll just say that
first of all i hope that you'll check
out the free chapter for manning chapter
three
is out there on the live book and
there's also the um
the article constraint satisfaction
problems in python which is a free
article based on chapter three that goes
into this in more depth
i will also give a shout out to my
twitter
at dave kopeck d-a-v-e-k-o-p-e-c
i try not to post anything political i
know people hate that on twitter so i
try to stay apolitical on twitter
and i mostly just post about computer
science topics or programming or i like
business i
write about what i post about a lot of
business stuff uh if you ever want to
ask me questions feel free to write a
tweet to me at dave kopeck
um the github my github username is
davecom
so d-a-v-c-o-m there's a link in the
below from manning just put up both to
my twitter and my github
and that's where you'll find the
repository for all the source code from
the class computer science problems
books
and look out later this year for class
computer science problems in java
i just want to really thank you for
taking the time i know everyone's
has busy lives and so i really
appreciate you taking the time to
spend with me in the last hour talking
about constraint satisfaction problems
in the books
and i hope you have a really wonderful
night and i hope everyone's safe
obviously during the pandemic which is
you know a difficult time to be
broadcasting during and i didn't know if
i should mention it or not during the
broadcast but you know i really hope
everyone's okay okay have a great day